Morgen.
Ganz gemütlich. Mal ein bisschen strecken. Kaffee schlürfen. Ihr Äuglein auf und die ersten Sonnenstrahlen auf der Haut. Guten Morgen. Es ist lächerlich kalt, muss man dazu sagen. Es ist tatsächlich sehr kalt. Wir haben Mikrofone im Wert von 4000 Euro, aber keine Heizung. Aber dafür Eiszapfen, die an diesem Mikrofon herabhängen. Da seht ihr unsere Prioritäten und unsere erste Priorität seid natürlich ihr, liebe Hörer des Podcast UFO Podcasts. Was ihr daran merkt, dass am 20. Januar die erste Folge kommt in diesem neuen Jahr. In diesem Sinne ein ganz tolles, frohes neues Jahr. Frohe Weihnachten und wir sind wieder da. Wir sind wieder da. Ach ey, ich habe es ein bisschen vermisst. So, oder? Ja. Manchmal ist es halt so, Weihnachten erlebt man halt manchmal so Sachen, die ganze Familie kommt zusammen, man erlebt Dinge, die man am sonst nicht... Onkel Harry, ich freue mich auf neue Anekdoten von dir. Der Onkel Harry hat mal wieder ein Volk beleidigt, massiv und gerantet.
Gibt es den Holocaust mittlerweile?
Nein.
Nope, alles klar.
Bei dir?
Nein, auch nicht.
Sollten sie eine Website machen, gibt es mittlerweile und dann erstes Jahr einfügen, wenn das wirklich passiert ist.
Nee, das ist ganz spannend und es passiert so viel.
Man hat einen ersten Weihnachtsfeiertag, man hat einen zweiten, einen dritten, einen vierten und das ist ganz spannend und es passiert so viel, man hat den ersten Weihnachtsfeiertag, man hat den zweiten, einen dritten, vierten und das ist ganz toll, weil da passiert immer so viel und ich wünsche mir, das wäre übers Jahr ein bisschen verteilt, dass man da immer was rauspicken kann oder dass es halt nochmal den 217. Weihnachtstag gibt, sodass den ersten, zweiten und dann einfach nochmal 217 einfach nochmal schön die besinnliche Stimmung aufgreifen. Und wo waren die anderen, 215? Nö, lass mal auf, man muss ja arbeiten, man muss ja die schmierigen Ketten des Kapitalismus weiter ölen. Ach, bin ich eh ein Gegner. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Bin ich ein Gegner. Finde ich nicht gut. Mag ich nicht. Was habt ihr so getrieben da draußen? Ich bin ein bisschen im Moin-Moin-Modus, ehrlich gesagt. Es ist so dieses, man wacht gerade auf, wöntelte. Dieses genuddelte, dieses, was habt ihr noch drauf? Was habt ihr, haut mal was raus, schreibt mal was in den Chat. Und dann musst du vier Minuten warten, bis die Deppen das im Stream haben, dann noch mal vier Minuten, bis sie gerafft haben, wo ihr Stift ist, dann dass wir das aufschreiben, dann ne, ich muss ja eintippen, und dann kommt zurück, ja, hier ist ein Bild von meiner Kaffeetasse. Ja, gut, danke, auch egal. Und dann kommt doch wieder die alten Bahngags, die du überlegst, die zwei, die dir... Du bist doch auch in der Bahn dann zum Moin Moin bestimmt und am Abend dann noch und hoffst die ganze Zeit, du bist so gebannt.
Bei jeder Person, die reinkommt, denke ich mir, komm schon, Bühne frei und bitte.
Ich brauche was für Magen, mach irgendwas Lustiges.
Stupp sie an, also werf Gepäck auf sie.
Nee, ich bin heute, wir fliegen heute, ich fliege heute nach Berlin, du fährst nach Berlin, weil wir heute so ein Funktreffen haben.
Tausend Jahre Funk wird heute gefeiert, endlich ist es soweit, wir haben schon lange auf diesen Tag gewartet. Das öffentlich-rechtliche Programm hat den neuen Triumph, den neuen grossen Aal an Land geholt und er zappelt noch. Was Florentina lustig zu kokettieren versucht, ist, dass es eigentlich nur, wie viel, zehn Tage, hundert Tage? Ich glaube, 14 Tage, Punkt, warte, warte, wir machen jede Woche eine Party, es ist behindert den Produktionsfluss leider so ein bisschen. Aber ich freue mich aufs Fliegen, ich freue mich auf den Flug und Rückflug freue ich mich am meisten, weil ich habe da so Spaß. Ich habe mir extra eine Sitzplatzreservierung gemacht, habe so eine Beinfreiheit, was bei mir einem normalen Sitz entspricht, weil meine Knie sind sonst immer im Rücken des Gegners, wie ich immer sage, des Vordermanns. Das ist immer nicht so einfach bei mir, aber ich freue mich. Also, das ist was ganz Tolles, so am Notausgang zu sitzen und das ist ganz toll. Du kannst auch, wenn du willst, alle in Abgrund stürzen. Ja, siehst du die Verantwortung, siehst du dich da erkannt, auch als Retter des Tages? Nicht als Retter, eher als der, ja, schon schon als Retter, jemand, der sie deren Zeit alle töten könnte.
So wenn die mir keinen,
nicht den dritten Martini einschüttet,
dann kann ich einfach sagen, ja, sorry,
ich bin am Nolausgang, ich kann einfach mit einem Ruck, mit einer Handbewegung
ist das Ganze zu. Ja, einfach so wortlos die Hand an den Hebel
legen. Mit einem Ruck ist
wir alle am Boden.
Ich glaube, du wirst einfach der sein, der sofort
ohnmächtig wird und alle anderen müssen über
deinen langen, schlachsigen Körper drüber steigen, um rauszukommen. Sorry, sorry, sorry. Und der scheiß Todessternkissen, was sich dann in Notausgang verheddert. Die Evok-Decke verheddert sich noch in der Lüftung. Sorry, sorry. Scheiße, ich glaube, die sagen nicht sorry. Doch, ich glaube, die sind trotzdem... Das ist das einzige Wort, was fehlt, wenn man in Not rausrennt in Notausgang. Aber du alle Sorys durch, ah Hilfe, ich sterbe, Hilfe, gefeuert! Aber ich glaube, diese Rutsche, die will ich mal ausprobieren. Das ist, glaube ich, Legende. Da gibt es keine Rutsche, das ist einfach nur so, damit die Kinder sich darauf freuen. Früher dachte ich, wie clever, man ist ja ganz oben, eine Rutsche kommt man ganz nach unten wieder, ganz gut. Ich dachte, die wäre 10.000 Meter lang, diese Rutsche.
Und für mich war es einfach nur
gross Spaß. Ja, Wärmeflugleiber.
Für mich war Not immer mit
Spaß verbunden, sehr doll.
Also 10.000 Meter Rutsche, geil.
Grossartig, mega gut. Das stimmt schon.
Man sollte das auch ein bisschen mehr motivieren, dass die Leute sich auf einen Unfall
freuen, so ein bisschen. Und wenn wir einen Unfall
bauen, dann kriegt ihr alle einen Keks.
Aber das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Dass ihr dann noch einen Mund habt, mit dem ihr den essen könnt. Aber wer hat da viel Spaß? Ah, Fluggags. Ah, Fliegen. Ich finde aber so großartig, dass jeder Comedian, den du dir anguckst, mindestens ein Flugzeugbit bei sich im Stand-Up hat. Aber es wird nicht alt. Es wird einfach nicht alt. Fliegen ist immer noch lustig. Aber hat nicht sogar Dr. Mario Barth eine gesamte Vorstellung in der Kulisse eines Flughafens gemacht, hat er nicht ein grosses Set gebaut für einen seiner Stand-Ups, dass er im Flughafen war? Sagt er eigentlich noch was, oder zeigt er eigentlich nur noch auf Gegenständen, die auf seiner Bühne stehen und Leute lachen, weil sie zum ersten Mal erkennen, was da gerade eigentlich ist? Er holt Leute aus dem Publikum einfach hoch und zeigt auf die Kette und einfach so, hä? Und alle so, ah, die trinken die Kette! Die ist grossartig, ja, ich finde das so gut! Ich habe 20 Euro dafür bezahlt, ich muss lachen! Nee, nicht 20, 120. Okay. Grossartig, ich bin abgehakt. Was hast du noch? Du hast noch ein bisschen Programm, du hast dir ein Programm überlegt. Die erste Folge, da hast du dir immer ganz wieder. Du, ich verballer meine heißesten Eisen in Moin Moin und hier ist dann noch so ein bisschen so der Abfall, was dann so unten rauskommt.
So beim Toaster, unten die Krümel.
Ich bin Skifahren am Wochenende und ich brauchte eine Skibrille.
Und die kann man nicht einfach so kaufen, da sind wir uns alle einig, oder da draußen?
Ja.
Weil die kannst du nicht einfach so, du hast keine Ahnung davon, aber das ist eine Industrie, seit tausend Jahren werden Skibrillen produziert, damals schon die alten Ägypter haben auf ihren Holzblöcken Skibrillen gemacht und ich denke mir dann, gut, ich muss diese Kunst irgendwie würdigen, indem ich die Brille kaufe, die für mich gemacht wurde speziell, die für Leute wie mich gemacht wurden, also bin ich in den Laden gegangen, ganz unübliche Sache, so ich bin bei Karstadt Sport gewesen, hab mir eine Skibrille kaufen wollen und dann war da halt ein Verkäufer für diese ganze große Abteilung da und der hat halt so ein Paar gerade geholfen, einen Helm und eine Skibrille zu finden und dann stand ich halt da vor den Skibrillen und habe halt gewartet, bis er endlich fertig ist, habe den aber die ganze Zeit zugehört und hat er irgendwann angefangen, ein anderes Paar zu bedienen und so und ich bin da nicht inzwischen gekommen. Also stand ich da bestimmt, das ist kein Scheiß, bestimmt anderthalb Stunden vor diesen Brillen und hab so getan, als würde ich mich nicht entscheiden können, um dann am Ende einzusteigen und zu fragen, welche Brille das für mich verzeihen kann. Weil was willst du machen? Du kannst nicht gehen, weil dann hast du nie eine Chance, du musst schon da bleiben und den Moment abwarten. Das ist auch so eine Situation, die mir nie passieren würde, weil ich immer möglichst versuche zu vermeiden, von dem Typen von dem typen angesprochen zu werden ich auch normalerweise aber was willst du bei skibrillen machen was willst du da holen na ja eine schöne skibrill kannst du einfach mal aussetzen und gucken wie es funktioniert aber muss man da auch mal ganz kurz anreißen wie kommentarlos man auch einfach hin ich weiß nicht ob das bei modernen modernen skibrillen auch noch so ist aber die skibrillen die ich hatte war es auch einfach so, dass die einfach gelbes oder rotes Glas hatten und man einfach völlig kommentarlos akzeptiert hat, dass wenn man die aufsetzt, einfach alles in gelb sieht. Und auch für den ganzen Tag, also für den gesamten Tag auf der Skipiste. Ich glaube, dass... Und dann machst du die ab und dann ist alles blau plötzlich. Ja, das ist verrückt, ja. Aber auch einfach so, ja, das ist die Wunder der Physik. Neue Euphorie im Podcast-Upho. Wow, wow. Aber einfach so, ich bin das erste Mal Ski gefahren, war ich sieben oder was weiß ich, habe ich einfach eine Skibrille bekommen und einfach hingenommen, dass ja, jetzt ist alles gelb und dann irgendwie nach Jahren fragt man sich so, Moment mal, muss das denn sein, warum ist hier alles gelb einfach immer?
Die Antwort, die wissenschaftliche Antwort darauf ist natürlich, dass du, wenn du Rottöne siehst, die Blautöne besser von dem Land unterscheiden kannst, weil das ist das Gegenteil, von der Wellenlänge her. Und dass du in der Schneewelt dann besser verschiedene Schneearten hast. Genau, die besser siehst du Kontraste und verschiedene Unebenheiten im Boden. Ja, im neuen Jahr habe ich mich vorbereitet. Ich habe zu allem recherchiert, was ich anschneiden wollen würde irgendwann heute und habe mir ein bisschen Background-Infos draufgeschaut. Meinst du Inuit sehen dann auch anders, wenn die nur weiss sehen? Also haben die dann andere... Die haben diese stechenden, roten, widerlichen Albino auch. Hasse Inuit, ey. Ich habe letztens wieder einen in der U-Bahn gesehen, irgendwie dick eingeparkt, dachte mir, du Vollidiot, hast vielleicht 16 Worte für Schnee, aber eins für Mundgeruch. Ich hasse Inuit so sehr, dass ich manchmal Eskimo sage. Auf jeden Fall, ja. Hat man da mal irgendetwas verletzt eigentlich? Ich glaube, eine Person. Du scheiß Eskimo, der sagt, jetzt ist mein Tag gelaufen. Ja, klar. Aber ich kann es ja verstehen, dass manche Worte einfach beleidigend sind. Irgendwann willst du das Neger-Arschloch oder Lumpen-Jude oder sowas sagst. Du musst nach Neger nicht noch Arschloch sagen. Aber Eskimo, ist das denn grossartig beleidigender als Inuit oder weniger beleidigend? Also man müsste vielleicht die Übersetzung wissen. Was ist das für eine Beleidigung in der Fremdsprache?
Ja. Was ist das, seit wann fangen wir an, also Neger ist ja nicht ein schönes deutsches Wort, das ist das deutscheste Wort überhaupt, aber Eskimo ist ja auch kein Inuit-Wort, oder nicht? Ja. Ich verstehe das nicht. In der Fremdsprache ist potenziell jedes Wort eigentlich eine Beleidigung. Ich verstehe nicht, wo das kommt, das Eskimo, keine Ahnung. Glaubst du, also wie ist es denn eigentlich so mit Mittelmenschen, so Mittelrassen, so zwischen Schwarz und Weiß? Also ab wann darf man so, also wenn du so einen Schwarzen siehst und sagst so, ey mein Bruder, ab wann darfst du das? Darfst du das schon, wenn du nur so ein bisschen schwarz bist oder darfst du das erst ab einem gewissen Ton? Ich glaube, noch schwieriger als Schwarze haben es die Mitteldinger, die nicht genau wissen, wo sie hingehören. Die wissen nicht. Kann ich jetzt rappen, weiß ich nicht. Ist das jetzt Rassismus oder kriege ich einfach nur, es gibt einfach wirklich kein Eis mehr? Also was ist jetzt? Darf ich die Leute abknallen einfach oder soll ich es einfach sein lassen? Habe ich einen grossen Schwanz oder nicht? Das sind diese Fragen, die man sich stellen muss. Und man weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, die einzige Antwort darauf haben amerikanische Polizisten, weil die irgendwann entscheiden müssen, okay, ab diesem Farbton mache ich dich fertig. Hängt aber auch viel mit dem Licht zu tun. Also es ist ja oft sehr unterschiedlich, total. Ich denke mir immer, wow, in diesem Lichtkreis siehst du mega aus und dann gehe ich daneben an, so einen Schritt nach rechts denke ich, ach komm. Und dann gehe ich wieder weg. Warum sagt man nicht statt Negerkuss einfach Megakuss? Also warum muss man das denn in Schokokuss umändern? Ich glaube, weil das nicht so geil ist. Die wissen selber, dass es nicht so geil ist. Ey, Schokoküsse ist schon richtig geil, muss ich sagen. Ich muss mal ganz kurz einen Shoutout an meine fucking Tante ausmachen. Ey, ihr habt zu Weihnachten ein Paket Schokoküsse bekommen, Negaküsse. Warum so? Man schenkt sich Geld und man verpackt das mit Dingen. Aber kann das nicht mal ein Buch sein oder so? Warum Negerküsse? Super Dickmanns. Aber weisst du, also zum Beispiel Judenküsse sind zum Beispiel auch solche Arten von Dingen, von denen man immer nur denkt, ja es gibt halt Dickmanns.
Aber Judenküsse finde ich wiederlich.
Ich finde das unangenehm.
Oh, würde ich wieder weglegen ins Regal. Aber da denkt man auch, es gibt nur die Dickmanns und die Billigen von Lidl, aber auch das ist ja eine gesamte Kultur. Zum Beispiel jetzt bei Käse, da weiss man, ah ja, okay, es gibt irgendwie den Geramont, Geramont, es gibt den Labello und es gibt den Babybel. und dann gibt es natürlich auch noch den Billigen von Aldi und Lidl, aber du weißt, dass es eine gesamte Käsekunst gibt. Und das ist, wenn du zum Käserei und dann gibt es noch den teuren und den ganz teuren und so. Aber bei zum Beispiel Produkten wie Schokoküssen ist das nicht so. Da denkst du, es gibt einfach nur die Dickmanns und die vom Lidl. Aber auch das ist falsch, meine lieben Freunde. Es gibt auch da eine ganze Schokokuss Kunst und Kultur. Geht zum Beispiel mal schön nach Nürnberg oder neben von Nürnberg oder sowas. Da gibt es diese Manufaktur. Geht einfach nach Hause. Oder geht ins Internet, Freunde. Informiert euch da mal, Leute. Und es gibt zum Beispiel, ich weiss genau wo, aber es gibt diese grossen Packungen, wo fünf mal fünf, also fünfundzwanzig Schokoküsse in der Packung sind. Und die sind richtig geil. Öffnet mal ganz kurz euren Horizont für diese ganzen Billigprodukte. Auch sowas wie Gummibärchen, denkt man auch, ja, Haribo und dann halt die Billigen von Lidl. Nee, auch da gibt es viel mehr, da gibt es eine riesige ...
Also es gibt mehr.
Bei Dickmanns wird es ja auch dann, wir sind ja unterteilt, in Neger, Latinos und Weiße. Was war dein Favorit da immer? Oh, die Weißen auf jeden Fall. Ich habe mich bis heute gefragt, warum es nicht die Weißen in Grosskript zu, einen richtig schönen, grossen Weißen, weil es ist immer so, dass bei den kleinen Dickmännchen, oder wie die heißen, dann immer die Weissen zuerst wechseln. Jeder mag die Weissen zuerst, dann die braunen und dann die schwarzen, aber nur die schwarzen gibt es als grosse. Vielleicht ist das sogar der Effekt, weil es die schwarzen als grossen gibt, man die nicht so gern mag, weil man die Abwechslung sucht. Aber man kennt die schon. Ich glaube, aber wenn es die Weissen als Grosse gibt, wahrscheinlich hat man das probiert. Ich denke mir immer, immer wenn ich eine Idee habe, denke ich mir, das hat wahrscheinlich schon mal jemand probiert und das hat nicht geklappt.
Die Tatsache, dass es das nicht gibt, heißt, dass es schlecht ist. Das heißt, alles, was ich mir Neues ausdenke, ist automatisch direkt schon schlecht. Das ist normal. Ich glaube, das ist aber jetzt gerade krass. Du kannst es zum ersten Mal richtig überprüfen, ob es das schon gibt, was du hast, weil du das Internet hast. Du kannst so, Einstein konnte nicht sagen, ach komm, es hat doch was zu tun. Gleich m. MC-Kontor, aber gut, es haben schon dreissig Leute rausbekommen. Ich meine, wenn ich es rausbekomme, ich Depp, so, dann haben es dann andere Leute rausbekommen. Nee, aber ich fand auch immer die Weissen am besten. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum. Aber warum gibt es da auch nicht, also die anderen Rassen, ich meine, es geht offensichtlich um Rassentheorie in diesem Dickmannskasten, wurden nicht berücksichtigt. Die Roten, die Gelben, so, die sind einfach nicht im Start. Mit Zitrone vielleicht. Das ist ein bisschen geärgert. Auf der anderen Seite darf man sich natürlich nicht verunzichern lassen von der Tatsache, dass es viele Ideen schon gab, weil man weiß ja nie, ob es die Idee wirklich schon nicht gab, dass wenn jetzt jemand eine Idee hat, wie zum Beispiel wir schneiden jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Äpfel in Stücke und verkaufen sie als Stücke, denkt man sich auch wieder, das hat bestimmt schon mal jemand gemacht, sowas in der Richtung, aber vielleicht hat es tatsächlich noch niemand gemacht und es ist ein riesiger Erfolg. Es werden jetzt Avocados verkauft, ohne Kerne, die einfach geteilt werden und dann ist dieser grosse Kern rausgenommen worden. Ja? Ja, aber ich weiß auch nicht genau warum. Bist du dir sicher oder hast du den einfach bei Lidl auf dem Boden gefunden, wo jemand draufgetreten ist? Ja, bei Lidl auf dem Boden geworfen, ja. Ich habe es selber geschnitten und dann gedacht und dann kurz vergessen, was passiert ist. Gestern bei Lidl, wir gehen in Lidl rein, denken geil, kaufen wir uns eine schöne Avocado und auf dem Boden liegen diese Erdnuss-M&Ms offen, zwei, drei Stück liegen da offen rum. Ja, und du bist erst mal wie ein Warzenschwein auf die Knie gegangen und du bist erst mal grunzend, da hast du die alle aufgelesen mit deiner miederlichen Nase. Ja, aber das ist immer so, dass sow sowas Verbotenes. Also kennst du das, wenn so eine Packung offen ist im Supermarkt? Das ist immer so ein extremer eine Drucksituation, aber auch so eine Grenzüberschreitung. Das ist so ganz offensichtlich, dass man das nicht darf. Ja, daraus zu essen, meinst du jetzt? Ja, ich greife da schon rein. Ich denke mir immer, die können doch schon monatelang hier liegen. Ja und? In diesem Siff-Lidl, die wissen doch gar nicht, was da los ist. Die wissen doch nicht, als ob die wissen, in der Gang E, Reihe 8 ist so ein Ding offen, da müssen wir mal kurz aufräumen. Nein, monatelang liegt das da rum und dann lundst du doch da ordentlich rein, obwohl das schon seit acht Jahren abgelaufen ist. Aber für mich hat das immer den Reiz der Grenzüberschreitung des Verbotenen. Das ist so wie auf dem Friedhof, man sieht jemanden, der so mit so einem halben Schuh im Grab steht und man denkt sich, das darf der nicht, das darf der nicht. Das habe ich bei Bahnen, bei dieser weissen Linie. Oh ja, oh je. Ich gucke den immer so an und immer so, ja, du wirst gleich sterben, das ist uns beiden klar. Denk mir auch. Du stehst ganz kurz davor, dein Testamentschreiben zu müssen. Vor allem, ich denke mir immer sogar, dass diese weisse Linie noch zu nah am Rand ist. Weil die Idee ist ja, dass wenn du umfällst nach vorne, dass dann selbst im liegenden Bereich noch der Schwerpunkt deines Körpers auf dem Landsteck ist, sodass du nicht reinklappst. Nein, die Idee, und deswegen hast du diese Schilder, wo der Mann weggesogen wird, ist, dass wenn du die da... Ich habe nie ein Schild gesehen, auf dem jemand weggesogen wird. Ich habe schon 30 Männer gesehen, die von einem Zug weggesogen wurden, ins All. Nein, in Carmen zum Beispiel, in meiner Heimat. Ja, diese Carmen-Stories, ey. Nein, du, ich komme nachher, das ist meine Heimat, das ist mein Herz, mein Herz. Keine Ahnung, wie man da spricht. War lange nicht mehr. Und dann bin ein Zug vorbei, rast. Die rasen manchmal da durch, durch den Marktplatz. Durch den Gleis. Und dann sind die so Vollkaracho-Fahne da durch, dass wenn du da so nah dran stehst, würdest du mit dem Sog, in einem Luftsog mitgesogen werden. Dann kommst du irgendwann in Hamm, Westfalen, kommst du auch aus. Ich stelle mir gerade den Bahnführer vor, wie der so einen grossen Regler hat, den er so hochstellt, von Pesen, Wetzen auf Carracho. Nee, von Bummeln auf Sausen, auf Carracho, Flitzen, Voll Carracho. Und dann Carracho und Voll Carracho. Und dann im Comic bricht es danach auch ab, der Stick, und dann sind wir beim Central Bullock-Film. Und auch auf so Strassenschellen auf der Autobahn steht nicht 100 kmh, sondern Karacho. Das finde ich immer cool. Oder blitzgeschwindend. Und dann so, oh, hier darf man nur blitzgeschwindend, wir müssen ein bisschen langsamer. Das fände ich schon lustig. Ja, fände ich auch lustig. Ein bisschen konkretere Zahlen einfach. 100 kmh ist nicht konkret, kann man sich nicht so so vorstellen. Gab es bei dir manchmal die Situation beim Supermarkt, dass du Dinge schon essen durftest und dann an der Kasse nur die Verpackung bezahlt wurde? Und zwar waren das diese Chemiebomben, diese Plastikflaschen, diese grossen, wo man oben diesen kleinen, wie nennt man das, diesen Nübel. Irgendwas und Trink. Dreh und Trink oder sowas. Dreh und Trink. Das ist einfach, das ist nicht mal, es schmeckt auch nicht nach Cola oder Kirsch oder Waldmeister, nein. Es schmeckt einfach nach irgendwas anderem Wasser. Es ist einfach nur Wassersulfat und Wasser und Farbstoff. Ich habe den Farbstoff so gelassen und sage, okay, komm, es schmeckt okay. Das ist nicht unser USP. Unser USP ist dieses Drehding. Scheiß da mal drauf. Man muss zugeben, man kauft es einfach, um es aufzudrehen und wie es schmeckt, ist dann egal. Und es schmeckt primär nach Plastik, aber das ist auch schön. Und das durfte ich immer schon aufdrehen und trinken im Supermarkt. Dann musst du dich auf die Kasse legen und dann wurde es dann da bezahlt. Wie zum Beispiel. Wow, du holst gerade Zigaretten aus deiner. Ja, Kaugummi-Zigaretten ist auch so ein Ding, ich habe immer schon die Packung dabei, die auch so sind, dass sie einfach schlecht schmecken. Kann ich mir mal eine Schnorren? Hast du ein Feuer? Klar, Mann. Auch hier ist das Problem, Kaugummi-Zigaretten sind eigentlich immer ganz geil und vor allem, warte mal, da steht sogar drauf, dass du beim ersten Mal, naja, nicht auf Lunge, nicht auf Lunge, da steht sogar drin, dass du beim ersten Mal reinpusten kannst und dann kommt Zauberkopf raus. Ja, und oh scheiße, mein einziger Prank, den ich jemals geschafft habe, ich kann nicht mal Kaugummi-Zigaretten rauchen. Das ist, wie unkool ich bin. Aber was auch vor allem so ist, was die einfach irgendwann gemerkt haben, dass es schlicht so ist, weil da irgendwie Rückstände von den Schuppen der Arbeiter noch irgendwie drin sind in den Kaugummi-Zigaretten, dass man die raus und dann haben die einfach gesagt, ja, dann machen wir einfach aus der Not eine Tugend und schreiben drauf, toller Zauberstaub kommt beim ersten Mal Blasen raus.
Weil man denkt, okay, anderes Wort für Krebs.
Ja, weiß ich auch nicht.
Das ist Pusten für dich, was ist ein Blasen?
Nee.
Nee, Pusten und Blasen ist dasselbe, oder?
Ah, weiß ich nicht. Pusten, Blasen ist eher mit mehr Karacho, wo wir wieder bei unseren Wörtern wären.
Pusten plus Karacho ist gleich Blasen.
Ja, genau.
Ich habe mal den ersten richtigen Prank, den ich geschafft habe,
durchzuziehen, war eine andere,
so ein bisschen so eine Requisiten-Karogummi-Zigarette,
die hat vorne noch ein bisschen rot gehabt,
sah als ob sie glüht, sah das aus.
Und die hat auch diesen Effekt, dass man reinpustet,
dann so ein, was auch nicht so aussieht. Ich meine, die wollen ja, dass man dieses Raucherlebnis nachempfinden kann als Kind, was schon mal eine fragwürdige Sache ist. Und dann schaffen sie es aber nicht ganz, weil anders als man bei Kaugummi-Zigaretten pusten muss, muss man ja inhalieren bei normalen Zigaretten. Das heißt, dieses Backen aufpusten sieht nicht so aus wie Rauchen, okay? Und man erkennt immer beim ersten Mal Rauchen die Vollidioten, die erstmal in die Zigarette reinpusten, weil sie so von Kaugummi-Zigaretten gewohnt sind, weil sie denken, ja, Stefan, Tiss, das ist vollidiotisch. Die wollen runterkommen von Kaugummi-Zigaretten und dann fangen sie an zu rauchen. Ich habe jetzt eigentlich nur noch diese Kaugummi-Pflaster eigentlich versucht runterzukommen. Und deswegen hat eine Lehrerin, hat mir erst mal durch den Gang gesaust zu mir und hat gesagt, wow, du kannst doch nicht rauchen. Da habe ich gesagt, das ist eine Kaugummi-Zearette, und habe abgebissen und bin weggegangen, wieder mega cooler Typ und musste nachsitzen. Gut, weil man auch nicht Kaugummi essen darf im Gang, keine Ahnung, aber das war mal ein Prank, da habe ich eine Lehrerin ein bisschen rangekriegt. Seitdem dann noch Stefan Danger, Stefan Smokey, und da habe ich dann noch Smokey genannt. Smokeyy-Tieze. Nann mich Smoky, ja. Ach Gott sei Dank sind wir wieder da. Wo würden wir sonst hin mit diesem Gehirn ausdünsten? Und wir haben tolle Nachrichten bekommen von euch, die ich jetzt alle nicht mehr weiss. Und wir haben 100 Euro bekommen von Paul. Mega krass, Paul, vielen Dank. Dollar, nicht Euro. Können Sie die anderen noch mal ein Vorbild dran nehmen und noch mal ein bisschen was raushauen, weil es macht auch mehr Spaß aufzunehmen, wenn man so ein bisschen zuhause war der Geldspeicher. Zaster dahinter ist, ne? Ich habe primär keinen Urlaub gehabt, muss ich ja mal sagen. Mich kommt immer diese scheisse Bachelorarbeit. Und ich habe Videos untersucht und bei einem Video... Also ganz kurz, du hast die Bachelorarbeit geschrieben, worum ging Genau. Es ging um die Veränderung der Massenunterhaltung im Internet. Ich hab dann YouTube-Videos untersucht, Inhaltsanalyse, weil das am einfachsten ist. Und dann gibt's da ... Und weil ich sie schon kannte. Und dann gab's da ein ganz tolles Video. Ich bin auf tolle Sachen gestossen. Ich muss dann auch wirklich drei Minuten 36 Neinkat gucken und dann nachher eine Inhaltsanalyse machen. Und dann, ich muss das wirklich durchgucken, weil es kann ja am Ende noch was Lustiges passieren, was man nicht erwartet, kann auch ein paar Werte mitvermitteln. Wie sieht die Inhaltsanalyse von Neoncat aus? Kannst du das mal, hast du es im Kopf? Ich habe 40 Variablen gehabt und dann sind da sowas wie Wertevermittlung und... Ernsthaft, 40 Variablen? Ja, und Unterhaltungsfunktionen werden aufgeteilt und so und... Was ist der Unterhaltungswert von Neoncat? Das kann man also nicht genau sagen, weil es für jeden was anderes bedeutet, aber primär Eskapismus schon. Es ist halt, weder bildet es, noch bringt es Informationen mit sich, noch hat es irgendeine soziale Kompetenz. Also Zulicherheitsgefühl, so ein Meme, wenn es alle kennen, kann man es auch. Genau, es gibt gerade die Variable gesorgt für Gesprächsstoff. Okay, jetzt mal eine andere Frage. Ist diese Facharbeit kompletter Bullshit, mit dem du dir versuchst, einen Studienabschluss zu erschleichen, oder hat die wirklich einen Wert? Ich denke mir, ich bin dann irgendwann mal in die Uni-Bibliothek gegangen, was eine ganz komische Sache für mich war, weil ich da noch nie war vorher, und habe mir dann einfach die ersten drei Bücher, die irgendwas mit Unterhaltung zu tun hatten, habe ich mir einfach genommen und geschrieben. Drei lustige Taschenbücher. Irgendwelche einfach so rausgenommen und die waren alle elementar wichtig für die Arbeit. Was sagt das mit meiner Arbeit aus? Dass ich die ersten drei Bücher, die ich irgendwo genommen habe, die ich nicht recherchiert habe, weil ich die jetzt brauche, um die Seiten zu füllen. Nein, das waren irgendwelche drei Bücher und die waren essentiell für meine Arbeit. Die haben 80% aller Zitale geliefert. Und ich mir denke, okay, irgendwas ist falsch gelaufen. Aber großartig war, ich habe viele Videos entdeckt, unter anderem ein Video, wo ein Flashmob war, das war irgendwann 2008 oder so, da war ein Flashmob beim Grand Central Station und da sind einfach so ganz viele Leute, die meisten Leute, die dann da in der Halle waren, dieser großen, die man ja auch kennt, sind eingefreezed und haben sich nicht mehr bewegt. Und die anderen Leute waren extrem verwirrt. Was ist gerade passiert? Das habe ich vor vier Jahren schon auf YouTube gesehen, die Treppe deppen. Was passiert gerade? Oh mein Gott. Und dann haben Leute angefangen, Fotos zu machen. Und dann dachte ich mir, Moment Gott. Ja, das habe ich auch gesehen. Das kann nicht sein, weil der Sinn eines Fotos ist, dass man sich darauf nicht bewegt. Was glaubt ihr denn
auf dem Foto nachher zu sehen?
So laufen sie zu den Freunden und sagen dann, ich habe dieses Foto
von diesem Freeze-Flash-Mom gemacht. Wahnsinn!
Das glaubt ihr gar nicht, mein Auto ist stehen geblieben,
hier ist ein Foto. Das glaubt ihr nicht, aber ich habe ein Foto.
Ich finde das so lustig, diese
Geistesblitzes, man will ja sofort was fotografieren,
aber leider hat es einfach keinen Sinn.
Das waren tolle Videos, die ich da entdeckt habe, unter anderem
das. Und dann auch so ein Megavideo, wie im Krüger Nationalpark in Amerika, ein Büffelbaby, getrennt wird von der Herde,
und dann entbrennt eine 15-minütige Verfolgungsjagd, wie Löwen auf dieses Baby einbeissen,
es rennt dann in den Fluss rein, warum auch immer, weil es sich da retten kann, weil die Löwen da nicht hinkommen,
kommt aber nicht ganz rein, dann kommt ein Alligator, fucking Natur, fucking Natur, ey, es ist krass, dann kommt der Alligator, beißt auch in das Baby, die Löwen fetzen sich um das Baby und mit dem Alligator und es wird zergerissen und die Leute rasten aus, die das Video machen, die können es gar nicht fassen und es geht wirklich mega lang, viel viel zu lang für ein YouTube-Video. Und es wird gefasst, dann kommt aber die ganze Herde,
die es inzwischen formiert hat, in so einer
krassen Formation, wo die Starken mit den
krassen Hörnern vorne stehen, laufen
auf dieses Schattbektakel zu, der Alligator
flieht, die Löwen fliehen, das Baby
flieht aber auch, das ist auch ein anderer von der Erde,
das Baby flieht, und dann kommt der nächste
Löwenangriff und so, und dann kommt die Herde
und dann kommen die krassen Herdentiere gegen
die krassen Löwen und am Ende überlebt das Baby. Das ist, wie geil ist die Natur bitte. Das ist eine gute Geschichte. Ja, mega geil, das ist so, die haben aus dem Sinne die krasseste Dramaturgie der Natur auf Video festgehalten, und solche Videos könnte man dann untersuchen. Das war toll, das war toll. Das ist gut, gefällt mir. Lass mal zusammen in so einen Nationalpark fahren, wo wir schön einmal die Natur geliesen lassen, schön ein bisschen Löwen angucken. So ein Löwe? So ein Löwe zu Hause? Ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, wie geil wäre es, wenn man keine Tiere klein züchten. Warum nicht? Wirklich? Klar kann man keine Tiere klein züchten. Alle? Ja, komm, ruf Philipp Hauptmann ein. Ja, okay. Ich dachte mir, wie geil wäre es, wenn man so kleine Giraffen oder Pferde hat auf dem Tisch, die man so auf dem Tisch, so ganz so kleine, fünf Zentimeter mal fünf Zentimeter grosse Tiere, die einfach so rumlaufen. Also eine Giraffe mit einem kurzen Hals, einfach so ganz normal, so wie die aussehen würde. Ich denke, so ganz kleine Tiere einfach, die einfach so am Tisch rumlaufen, die sich auch in Lego-Landschaften einfach zu Hause fühlen würden. So, und wo man dann den so was kleines, so ein M&&M in den S und der kann ein Jahr davon leben. So ein ganz kleiner Giraff halt, die dann so über den Tisch stolziert dann immer, die dann auch so umwerfen kann. Schöne gute Idee. Ich weiß nicht, ob das funktioniert, aber es ist auch eine gute Idee. Ich weiß echt nicht, ob es funktioniert. Ich glaube auch allein schon bei den meisten Hunderassen, die man heute so kennt, die sind so kaputtgezüchtet, dass sie innerlich einfach schon sterben. Ich habe da mal so eine Doku gesehen, dass sie immer so süss, ah, der tappelt immer so süss mit seinen Füssen und so, das sieht so lustig aus, weil er dafür sorgt, dass er 80 Tumore hat, die zusammengewachsen sind und er einfach irgendwie nicht und er einfach Schmerzen hat den ganzen Tag. Oh, der lächelt so süss, nein, er hat Schmerzen die ganze Zeit seines Lebens. Oh, nach dreihaliten Jahren ist er tot, zum Glück, dann können wir uns neun kaufen. Ja, der hat einfach gelitten drei Jahre lang. Aber, jetzt kommt die Frage.
Die Tiere leben immer so lang, dann sind die nicht so süss.
Ja, der ist einfach nur Welpe und dann stirbt er nach fünf Monaten.
Frage, ähm,
weiss er, dass er leidet?
Weil es das einzige Leben, was er kennt.
Das stimmt.
Weiss, ist das nicht auch, was wir gerade durchmachen,
ein riesen Leid tragen?
Vielleicht leiden wir eigentlich viel zu sehr, ja.
Vielleicht schaut eine Alien-Rasse auf uns herab und sagt,
mein Gott, er löst sie doch endlich von ihrem Leid. Warum malen wir den Mond nicht an wie einen Todesstern, damit wenn Aliens vorbeikommen, die sagen, ah, Star Wars. Kenn ich. Geil. Ja. Coole, coole Rasse. Ja. Das wird aber cool, so ein Merchandise-Mond, der einfach... Oh ja, irgendjemand hat uns eine Nachricht geschrieben zu dem Ketten-Thema. Warte, die suche ich mal raus.
Nee, genau, ich weiß die glaube ich noch. Und zwar haben die da wirklich mal im Physikkurs oder so darüber nachgedacht, was für ein Material man nehmen müsste. Ja, es war meine Idee war, dass man eine große Kette legt von der Erde zum Mond oder zum Saturn und die beiden Planeten einfach zusammenbindet, um dann einfach mal zu schauen, was passiert. Ja.
Ja, also würden die dann irgendwie von ihrer Bahn abkommen oder irgendwie würde es dann so ein Kugel-Effekt oder so ein Gottscher, so ein Billard-Effekt, so Tok.
Den typischen Kugel-Effekt, ich glaube, den gibt es.
Ja, ich habe ja leider kein Internet, aber das stimmt, er hat gesagt, dass es noch kein Material auf der Erde gibt, das dafür geeignet wäre, weil glaube ich auch, dass es unter seinem eigenen Gewicht zusammenbrechen würde, weil die Kette ja so unfassbar lang sein müsste, dass sie selbst ja auch so viel wiegt, dass sie ihr eigenes Gewicht tragen muss, aber wohin denn, weil es ist doch keine Schwerkraft, wenn du im All bist, also Gewicht gibt es doch nur, wenn es Schwerkraft gibt, dann ist es auch. Aber Schwerkraft ist ja gleich Gewicht. Ja eben, aber es gibt ja, ab wenn du so irgendwie 20 Meter in die Luft springst, gibt es ja keine Schwerkraft mehr.
Und die Kette ab dann muss ja ihr eigenes Gewicht nicht mehr tragen, sondern nur in dem Bereich, nah am Saturn und nah an der Erde. Aber vielleicht ist sie selbst das schon. Ich höre schon wieder das Augenrollen der Physikstudenten bis hierhin. Vielleicht ist selbst das schon zu viel. Nee, weil die Kette ist ja an sich schwer und dadurch hat sie eine eigene Gravitation. Deswegen zieht sie so zusammen vielleicht. Ja, ich glaube, ja, das stimmt. Ja, dann sagen alle auch, keine Ahnung, geht er also nicht. Und dann ist sie weg. Ja, das ist mir auch schon passiert. Heute Morgen, ich hatte mal so einen Stuhl, aber die Eigengravitation hat ihn einfach implodieren lassen, dann ist er weg. Kann man sich eigentlich auf links drehen? Ja, das geht. Also zum Beispiel in David Cronenbergs Die Fliege gibt es ja da so einen Moment, wo er so einen Affen hat in seiner Teleporterbox und wenn er die aufmacht, dann ist er so komplett auf links gezogen, der Affe. Dann ist ja das innere Außen und das äussere Inneren.
Und wo hat man angefangen?
Tot.
Nee, jetzt mein, wo am Körper hat man angefangen, auf links zu drehen? Welche Öffnung hat man genommen?
Mund, würde ich sagen, weil du den Mund nimmst und so durch den Mund sein Inneres nach außen stülpst und dann am Ende hast du den Mund halt wieder nur auf der anderen Seite. Und dann bist du halt tot. Aber auf links. Gestorben bei seiner Lieblingsbeschäftigung, auf links drehen. Oder auf dem Grabstein dann auch stehend, Stefan Titzel in Klammern, auf links. ZwinkerSmiley. Ja. Oh, Grabstein und ZwinkerSmilies? Wie werden sich Grabsteine verändern? Meinst du, es wird mal in so eine große Revolution kommen, dass es halt so Tablets sind oder so oder da so eine Slideshow läuft? Ich glaube, Grabsteine werden aussterben, weil Leute nicht mehr in diesen traditionellen Bullshit glauben und deswegen lassen die einfach mal nehmen. Warum? Ich meine, man kann in den letzten zehn Jahren keine Veränderung der Totenkultur beobachten. Es gibt vielleicht mehr Urnen, gut, okay, gekauft, aber vom generellen Totenkult gibt es keine Unterschiede. Das Internet und die Modelltechnik... Jetzt wissen wir auch, was Florian die in den letzten Monaten gemacht hat. Er hat den Totenkult recherchiert und herausgefunden, dass es... Er hat eine quantitative Inlandsanalyse durchgeführt, ob es da irgendwie eine Veränderung gab und hat herausgefunden, nein. Spannende Erkenntnis. Ja, weil in der Regel alte Leute sterben und denen sind dann Traditionen vielleicht wieder nicht. Du hast keinen Bettler. Für dich haben alle deine Erkenntnisse für mich keine Aussagekraft. Das ist alles so uninformiert Scheiße. Such dir mal drei Bücher und dann guck mal, wie die dir weiter helfen. Egal welche, ist auch egal welche. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, ich glaube schon, dass sich das verändern wird. Aber ich glaube auch immer ironische, das sollte ironisch mit dem Tod umgehen und dann lustige Sachen auf den Grabstein schreiben oder so.
Ist aber schwer, wenn du jetzt in dein Testament schreibst, irgendwie was lustiges, keine Ahnung, Stefan Tietze falsch geschrieben oder so, Gag, Typo oder dann halt so wie bei der Autokorrektur, wird dann angezeigt, so meinten sie, der coolste Typ, der jemals gelebt hat, irgendwie sowas hätte ich gerne auf meinem Grabstein. Aber dann ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung, dein Kind oder so muss dann deine Beerdigung organisieren.
Dann denkst du dich, soll ich das jetzt wirklich machen?
Natürlich macht er das aber. auf meinem Grabstein, aber dann ist irgendwie keine Ahnung, dein Kind oder so muss dann deine Beerdigung organisieren, denkst du dich, soll ich das jetzt wirklich machen? Weil es geht ja eigentlich nicht mehr um dich bei deinem Grabstein und deinem Tod, sondern um alle anderen, die um dich trauern. Ja, und es gibt tatsächlich... Eigentlich ist es nicht mehr deine Verantwortung, dein Tod. Ich bin ja gerne bei Steinmetzen, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ich liebe es. Ich liebe den Geruch, bei Steinmetzen zu sein. Frischer Granit. Und dann steht da vorne ja immer so Probe-Grabstein, wo man drauf zeigen kann, ja, den will ich.
Und da stehen oft grosse Elefantensteine.
Also ich kenne einen Steinmetz an einem Friedhof, wo grosse Elefanten stehen.
So kleine, also die sind wirklich wie so dieses Grundgerüst von einem Grabstein, so groß,
und dann wird da draufsteht, so ein Riesenelefant. Und da da drüber steht dann hier Ruth und dann kann man da einfügen, wer da ist. Dumbo. Und wer holt sich sowas? Keine Ahnung. Und wie geil ist das? Keine Ahnung. Aber wie geil, stell dir mal vor, du willst dann deinen verstorbenen Vater huldigen und dann gehst du zum Friedhof und dann bittest du so einen grossen Elefanten an. Ich glaube, das ist so eine schwere Entscheidung, dass man sich letztlich immer auf Traditionen beruht. Ich glaube, genau dafür sind Traditionen ja da, für Entscheidungen, die man selber nicht treffen möchte, sondern die Kultur für einen übernimmt. Und wenn es einfach eine Scheissentscheidung so, soll ich jetzt irgendwie den Pfau oder den Elefanten nehmen, ist das dann peinlich, ist das dann respektlos? Nö, du nimmst einfach das, was alle seit Jahrtausenden nehmen. Deswegen ist seine Tradition mega nützlich und niemand hat die Motivation, die Tradition zu ändern, deswegen wird das bestehen bleiben, glaube ich. Ich will nur Grabräuber abschrecken. Auf jeden Fall. Die dann bei mir reinkommen und bei mir irgendwie meinen Ring, meinen goldenen Diamantring, den ich bis dahin erworben habe. Ja, du kannst ja auch dann so, wurde schon geplündert oder sowas draufschreiben. Ja, auch ein ganzer Sonnenbrillensmiley.
Ach man, ja, Ironie auf Grabstein funktioniert auch nicht, weil die müssen ja tausend Jahre verweilen und dann irgendwann ist der Humor auch nicht mehr, dann fragen die sich und dann legen die es vielleicht auch aus als, sagen wir mal so, so Illuminati-Zeugs. Ja, dann hast du verloren. So einen Weg suchen. dann sehen die da, wenn da so eine Art Pfeil drauf sein könnte, dann verfolgen die den Pfeil und suchen dann halt wie im alten Ägypten, Indiana Jones Style. Ja, aber mit dem Tausendjahre finde ich interessant, zum Beispiel bei Atommüll, habe ich auch eine Doku gesehen, dass man bei Atommüll, das baut man ja irgendwie in so ein Bergwerk rein oder so und das muss dann halt einfach 4000 Jahre liegen, dann ist es nicht mehr radioaktiv, aber das dauert halt eine Weile. Und die mussten sich wirklich richtige Gedanken machen, wie man da die Warnenweise strukturiert. Weil wenn du da jetzt hinschreibst, ey Leute, bitte nicht weitergehen, radioaktiv, vielleicht in 1500 Jahren gibt es einfach die Sprache nicht mehr. Und die Leute verstehen es nicht und gehen da rein. Das ist doch bestimmt mega, mega, mega geil. Ja. Aber mega, mega geil, das müssen ja auch so krasse Orte dann sein, irgendwie so Schnee, ich stehe mir so einen Zacken Schneepalast vor, wo man dann denkt, aber wenn da steht, Achtung, radioaktiv, will ich natürlich reingehen, weil ich denke, hier wohnt fucking Superman. Ja, wie cool. Ja, aber du musst irgendwie Zeichen entwickeln, die zeitlos einfach klar machen, hier ist nicht geil. Und dann machst du ein großes rotes X oder einen Totenkopf, aber vielleicht ist Totenkopf in zehn Jahren halt mega cool, weil die Emus an der Macht sind. Und dann... Emus? Ja. In dieser Welt will ich nicht leben. Nein. Aber kann man nicht einfach unter dem Atomzeichen so ein Sternchen machen und sagen, bitte nicht verändern in den nächsten tausend Jahren. Das kann sein, ja. Geschrieben 2016. Wäre ganz geil, wenn dir das... Ganz kurz. Lass du mich das bei jeder Erwähnung. Ernsthaft jetzt mal. Ohne Scheiss, verändert das einfach nichts. Aber glaubst du, es wird jemals eine andere dominante Rasse geben, ausser den Menschen auf der Erde? Also ich meine, irgendwann waren es die Dinosaurier, jetzt sind wir es Menschen und irgendwann gibt es ja wahrscheinlich was anderes. Aber was denn? Ja, gute Frage. Oh, Douglas Adams würde jetzt die Mäuse sagen oder die Delfine. Ich glaube eher an Karibus. Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, wir werden immer dominant sein, weil wir immer sehen können, oh, die rebellieren gerade, oh, die Emus werden zu schlau, die können sprechen, zack, Kopf ab, können wir immer machen, kein Problem. Nein, nein, nein, wir machen Experimente mit denen, Experimente, bis die Experimente schiefgehen, das kennen wir aus jedem Film, Florentin. Ja, aber dann manipulieren wir die, dass sie halt nur noch dann irgendwie die Sachen sagen, die wir wollen.
Ich habe übrigens Teil zwei zu der
Will you marry me Nummer,
wie wir in der letzten Folge angesprochen haben,
vor der letzten Folge, da ist jetzt mittlerweile können Affen,
haben die in Orang-Utan Sprechen beigebracht.
Und zwar haben die
den halt konditioniert, dass immer wenn er
Hi sagt, kriegt er was zu essen. Und dann sagt er immer Hi und sagt auch morgens Hi, wenn Leute da vorbeikommen und so. Und dann ist es einfach guselig, weil die einfach furchtbar klingen. Die klingen alle wie ein ganz, ganz alter, schrecklicher Mann, der schon 30 Kinder vergewaltigt hat und dich auch 30 vergewaltigt. Und noch mindestens 30 weitere vergewaltigt will. Und es ist furchtbar. Es klingt ganz schlimm. Aber die wissen ja nicht, was sie sagen, oder? Er meint doch, weil die haben jetzt auch mehrere Wörter beigebracht bekommen, dieser eine, auch an Utan, und er sagt jetzt auch je nachdem, was er will, andere Wörter. Naja, aber dann ist das einfach eine Übersetzung von den Lauten in die Worte. Was war der Anfang der Menschen? Der Menschen. Geil, es geht um die Ursprünge des Sprechens. Spätestens wenn er so eine Form Grammatik drauf hat, dass er Worte deklinieren und konjugieren kann und Worte zusammenführen kann, dann ruf mich an, dann bin ich beeindruckt. Bis dahin nicht. Okay. Wenige wissen, dass erst das Husten da war, um Dinge aus der Lunge rauszubekommen, um zu überleben, und dann Sprache erst. Ernsthaft? Ja. Was denn? Guten Abend! Das war sozusagen die Entwicklung der Sprache. Ich habe wirklich Husten. Das war die Entwicklung der Sprache, tatsächlich. Aus dem Husten und Lachen gab es Lachen vor Sprache? Nein, es gab keinen Humor vor Sprache. Nichts Lustiges. Woher weißt du das denn eigentlich immer, Stefan? Ja, ich habe mal... Du sagst das mit so viel Selbstbewusstsein. Ich habe mal ein Referat über die Stimme gehalten. Das habe ich schon mal erzählt. Da habe ich auch, da wo ich Korken gegeben habe und die ganze Klasse gesagt hat, weil ich den Korken ausgeteilt habe. Und das war auch das Referat, wo ich erzählt habe, dass erst das Husten da war. Das war wirklich so.
Und da bilden sich auch Laute, dann kamen erst die Vokale, erst waren die Vokale da. Und dann irgendwann kommt da raus, bildet man dann mit den Lippen und der Zunge, bildet man dann verschiedene Konsonanten.
Tipp zum Thema Referat, habe ich einmal gemacht in der Schule, wenn ihr euch selber Themen aussuchen dürft, sucht euch ein Thema aus, das so speziell ist, dass ihr davon ausgehen könnt, dass der Lehrer sich auch nicht damit auskennt und sagt dann einfach irgendwas oder sagt so Halbwahrheit und improvisiert einfach. Und es ist kein Problem, weil der Lehrer wird sicher nicht die Mühe machen, sich im Vorhinein damit auseinanderzusetzen, wenn man noch nicht weiß genau, was man sagen wird und auch nicht im Nachhinein zu recherchieren, ob das alles gestimmt hat, weil es ist ein Referat. du kannst im Nachhinein immer behaupten, ne, ich hab gesagt 1820, ne, du hast gesagt 1409, ne, 1820, oder, äh, Ronny, ja, ne, 1820. Möchte ich ganz kurz mal einen fucking Shoutout, ähm, das regt mich bis heute noch auf, manchmal ist so fucking Dinge, die passiert sind, die mich immer noch aufregen und so, ich hab mein Referat gehalten, Buchrefer und habe halt nur Scheiße erzählt. Und hinten in dem Buch war halt so eine Karte drin von dem Bauernhof, auf dem das Ganze spielt. Und dann habe ich diese Karte kopiert und ausgedruckt und verteilt, bin aber nie darauf eingegangen, habe es nie darauf Bezug genommen, weil es mir egal war, weil ich halt irgendwas austeilen wollte, einfach weil es immer gut kommt, wenn du Dinge austeilst, okay, Vorbereitung. Und dann hat einer nach dem Referat jemand gefragt, so, jaha,
aber wer ist jetzt Ron? Da steht
Rons Hütte und hier steht Beons
Haus. Wer ist das denn?
Ich so, Alter, hast du einen Schaden? Das ist scheißegal,
ey. Flutin, Flutin, Flutin.
Diese Wörter wollen wir im Referat
nicht hören, okay? Aber wirklich so
rotzfrech in den Rücken
gefallen. Und wir denken so, auf welcher Seite bist
du denn hier? Bist du auf meiner? Ganz normales Referat, dann eine Gegenfrage, was willst du eigentlich, du Arsch doch? Halt mich zurück, halt mich zurück. Also auf gar keinen Fall bei Referaten Fragen stellen. Hat noch jemand Fragen, ist immer, immer eine rhetorische Frage, immer. Ich habe immer, es heißt, hat noch jemand Fragen, heißt nichts anderes als, das Referat ist zu Ende. Ich glaube, wir waren auf unterschiedlichen Seiten in der Klassendynamik. Ja, auf jeden Fall, du warst mein Feind. Ich habe Leute wie dich fertig gemacht, natürlich habe ich Fragen gestellt. Weil ich wusste, ah, der kleine fette Junge muss ja nach vorne, die Fette ist wieder nach vorne und muss ein Referat halten. Wenn jemand in meiner Klasse die Fette genannt worden wäre, hätte ich den natürlich fertig... Warst du ein Bulli eigentlich? Die ersten Jahre mit Sicherheit. Klar. Jeder, der nicht dick ist, ist ein Bulli automatisch. Jeder, der nicht auffällt. Ein Rüpel? Ja, Rüpel. Jeder, der nicht auffällt durch irgendwelche unnatürlichen Merkmale, ist per se erstmal ein Bulli. Das ist die Regel. Und deswegen habe ich Leute wie dich natürlich gegen Fragen gestellt. So schön, warum ist das so ein kleiner schmaler Gang und warum ist der so eingezeichnet auf dem Zettel, den du ausgeteilt hast?
Und dann, natürlich hätte ich dich in die Einbahnstraße laufen lassen, in offenen Messer.
Ich hasse dich einfach.
Ich glaube echt, wir haben uns zu einem guten Timing getroffen.
Ich glaube, in fünf Jahren hassen wir uns und vor fünf Jahren hätten wir uns auch gehasst.
Ja, ich glaube auch.
Aber jetzt geht's, jetzt geht's einigermaßen.
Jetzt halten wir uns gerade so aus.
Ja, es ist so, die Grafen überschneiden sich gerade, aber ich glaube, du triffst es noch mal in eine ganz andere Richtung ab. Ich glaube bei dir, und das meine ich ernst, ich glaube bei dir kommt noch mal eine richtig spirituelle Phase. Echt jetzt? Ja, du entdeckst irgendwie auf einer Party oder so, redest du mit so einem Guru über irgendwie transzendentale Meditation und Buddhismus und so und dann so deine Euphorie kommt und dann steigst du dich total rein und dann liest du das und so ja und dann hast du so eine Art Erleuchtungserlebnis irgendwie, weil du irgendwie deine Lampe dir zu lange ins Auge geleuchtet hat, hast du irgendwie so ein Flimmern und dann denkst du, oh ich hab Gott gesehen und so und dann driftest du komplett ab in so eine Sekte, weil du dich so schnell begeistern bist. Ein Problem, du hast das Wort Party benutzt, wo ich die kennenlernen, okay. Das dauert halt jetzt noch fünf Jahre, bis du auf einer Party bist, aber dann. Anderes Problem, also wo du recht haben könntest, ist, dass ich sehr begeisterungsfähig bin. Aber ich bin nicht sehr leicht, glaube ich. Aber ich glaube schon, dass ich mich wohl auch begeistern könnte trotzdem, wenn ich da lange noch darüber nachdenke. Aber bist du dann jemand, der mich dann rauszieht aus diesem Sumpf, wo du merkst, okay, mit ihm geht es gerade massiv bergab. Na, ich glaube, es ist schwer. Es ist nicht schwer. Ich würde es auf einer gewissen Art auch unterstützen.
Ich glaube, das würde dich glücklich machen.
Ich glaube, das weltliche Leben ist nicht für dich gemacht.
Warum legst du mir immer so eine Unglücklichkeit aus?
Ich glaube, ich bin mit einer der fröhlichsten Menschen, die ich kenne.
Ja, aber fröhlich ist manchmal das Gegenteil von glücklich.
Du attestierst mir immer, du willst mich immer in so eine Ecke schieben.
Ich bin selber unglücklich mit deinem Leben.
Ich glaube, dein Konsumzwang kann dich langfristig nicht glücklich machen, dein komischer Nerd-Eskapismus. Sagt der mit seinem Schein, der eine Armbrust fürs Büro gekauft hat, der eine fucking Gratis-Kaugummi-Zigaretten in die Nase gerieben hat. Ja, das ist ein Gesamtwert von 15 Euro. Du kaufst dir für 1000 Euro ein Boosted-Board. Ist das mittlerweile angekommen oder ist die Firma schon wieder pleite gegangen wie Tesla?
Es kam eine Mail, wo sie sich ausführlich für die Explosion entschuldigt haben, gesagt haben, okay, wir sind da dran, wir sind da dran. Aber es sah sehr cool aus. Es sah cool aus. In der Zwischenzeit sind weitere 20 Mitarbeiter gestorben, aber wir sind drauf, wir haben den Weg herausgefunden, raten aber ab, im Regen zu fahren. Das ist ein bisschen wertmindernd. Ichlegt, ob ich es dir abbestelle, weil ich bin Regenfahrer, ich rase durch die Pfützen.
Auf jeden Fall, aber zum Thema Versumpfung ist ja, ich war in deiner Heimat, habe mit alten Freunden geredet und habe auch gemerkt, dass einer meiner alten Freunde langsam politisch ein bisschen abdriftet oder eigentlich schon abgedriftet ist und jetzt auf der rechten Seite ist, AfD-Anhänger ist. Und es ist echt sehr interessant, sich damit zu beschäftigen, weil man denkt ja so, okay, der hat einfach nur die falschen Sachen gelesen, der hat sich in den falschen Foren rumgetrieben, der kennt die Fakten nicht oder so und kennt halt unsere Sicht der Dinge nicht. Und dann denkt man sich, okay, wenn man ihm die erklärt, dann passt es schon wieder. Und dann erklärt man ihm die und dann sagt er, nö, der steht da schon wirklich fest dahinter und der kennt die Gegenseite auch und so, zwar natürlich durch die Brille von AfD-Anhängern, aber an sich ist er da wirklich dagegen und er ist dann wirklich dagegen, dass irgendwie Homosexualität in der Schule gelehrt werden soll, als das gibt's auch und ist okay, so und dann denkt man sich, ja gut, okay, das wird dann schwierig. Man denkt immer so, man kriegt den Punkt noch, wo man jemanden dann wieder so auf die richtige Bahn kegeln will, aber man denkt dann, okay, nee, es ist eigentlich schon zu spät, es ist wirklich interessant. Ja, wo wir auch so ein bisschen wieder bei Filterblasen werden, weil die werden immer, man wird ja immer in seiner Seite bestärkt einfach. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Man kriegt nur noch Spiegel-Ondon-Artikel angezeigt, die dir das anzeigen, was du glaubst. Genau, ja. Es ist halt echt hart, aber das ist einfach so, die wollen Klicksleute, die wollen Verweildauer auf Seiten und natürlich funktioniert Facebook so, dass die Interaktionen wollen. Deswegen geben die Dinge, von denen du wissen, dass du es willst. Und man merkt auch, wie man langsam sich immer weiter rein argumentiert in genau das Feindbild der Leute. Dass man genau zum Beispiel irgendwann so einen Begriff benutzt wie White Privilege, wo man genau merkt, bei dem anderen triggert der, weil das genau das ist, was er sich über Leute lustig macht, wie irgendein White Privilege, Frauen werden benachteiligt, ja, so und schreit. Und dann kommen die immer mit, und dann weiss er genau, was es für Werder sind. Genau, ja, und die machen sich darüber lustig, das ist genau dieser Feinbild von diesem Kack, der irgendwie sich nicht um seine Frauen kümmert und irgendwie dann seine Frauen vergewaltigen lassen will. Ist ja aufgefallen, dass es keine Diskussionen mehr gibt, sondern nur noch Seiten, die gegeneinander argumentieren. Wann es ist wirklich schwer. Aber wann ist das passiert? Also ich habe das Gefühl, irgendwann gab es das nochmal, dass man Leute, man kann Leute nicht mehr, man kann Leute nicht mehr auf seine Seite holen, gefühlt. Ja, aber es stimmt schon, weil es ist ja auch so, er will mich auf seine Seite holen und ich auf seine Seite und beide denken, ja es ist nur noch eine Frage der Zeit, bis man merkt, dass der andere Recht hat, aber man kommt da einfach nicht mehr raus. Ich weiß nicht, ob es schon immer so war, dass es einfach so festgefahren war, aber irgendwie ist es jetzt vielleicht extremer. Ich weiß es nicht, aber krass. Ich weiß nicht, ob man in der Nazizeit auch das nicht hier. Also hast du irgendwo Leute, wo du denkst, oh la la la la, uiuiuiuiui. Da nicht unbedingt. Aber ich lese auch gerade so ein Buch über die Nazi-Anfangszeit und es ist schon sehr interessant, wie die damals das beobachtet haben, wo auch viele gesagt haben, auch als dann die Nazis an der Macht waren,
haben viele gesagt, ja, die haben keinen wirklichen Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung und die Regierung wird sich nicht lange
halten können, das ist eigentlich kein Problem, das ist natürlich
mal ein populistischer Ausreisser und so,
wie man es jetzt vielleicht bei Trump betrachtet
oder so, wo man sagt, ja, das ist mal ein Ausreisser
und so und die haben auch sehr gut beschrieben,
dass es auch da einen starken Meinungspluralismus gab,
also dass nicht alle sofort auf der
Naziseite waren, sondern auch viele dagegen waren und es viele auch Diskussionsgruppen gab und auch öffentliche Diskussionen. Wie Scheiße finden wir Jungs jetzt genau. Ja genau, die viel darüber diskutiert haben, aber es hat dann am Ende nichts gebracht, weil gerade dadurch irgendwie man auch so das Gefühl hatte, dass es politisch noch sich was bewegen kann und so und man darüber diskutiert hat, Aber einfach politisch mit der Machtübergreifung, als so viele Hebel gelegt wurden, dass es ab einem gewissen Punkt ein Selbstläufer war und einfach irgendwann einfach, es zwar für das Alltagsleben jetzt keinen Unterschied macht, aber im politischen Sinne einfach Hebel gelegt werden, die so schnell nicht mehr rückgängig gemacht werden können, die einfach dann irgendwann dazu führen, dass irgendwann einfach ein Gesetz erlassen wird. Und die beeinflussen dann auch wieder das Denken. Auf jeden Fall, und selbst wenn 70% der Bevölkerung gegen Gesetz ist, sobald es mal in Kraft ist, ist es sehr schwer, dann noch dagegen zu produzieren und man, okay, das ist jetzt halt so, ja okay, gut ist halt eingesetzt, das uns nicht gefällt, aber wir sind da dagegen, aber wir handeln halt trotzdem danach. Und irgendwann wird es aber mehr. Und am Endeffekt hast du eine Bevölkerung, die vielleicht nicht 100% dafür ist, aber einfach in einer Welt lebt, die schon nach den Regeln geordnet ist, die eingesetzt wurden.
Kleiner Funfact zum Schluss noch mal, wo wir gerade bei Spiritualität waren auch und so eine Leichtglaubigkeit. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es gelesen hast, es gab diese Frau irgendwo in Peru, die die ganze Zeit eine Figur angebetet hat, die sich für die Gottheit hielt und es hat sich herausgestellt, dass es Elrond ist von Heide Ringe. Das ist ein spannender Perspektivwechsel. Aber ich finde auch geil, wenn plötzlich die krasse Elben-Ermächte oder so gehabt hätte. Aber sie hat einfach die ganze Zeit Elrond von Herr der Ringe angebetet. Und dann ist irgendwann die Tochter nach Hause gekommen, hat sie dann fotografiert und hat gesagt, das ist nicht die heilige Madonna, die du anbetest. Das ist einfach jetzt leider Herr der Ringe. Auch sehr mächtig. Ja, also schon seit tausend Jahren hat gegen Soran gekämpft. Kannst du auch anbeten, ich will das jetzt nicht verbieten, aber das ist nicht das, wo du meinst, dass es ist. Das ist schon lustig. Es gibt ja auch dieses Bild, wo auch so Jesusbilder durch Obi-Wan Kenobi ersetzt wurden. Aber wie fängt jetzt an, wenn ihr jetzt überlegt, okay, meine letzten fünf Jahre Gebete sind falsch, fange ich wieder von vorne an. Bete ich dich für die gleichen Sachen und entschuldete
sie sich, sorry, dass ich verwechselt habe, ich habe kurz
mit jemand anderem gesprochen, aber hier bin ich wieder.
Jetzt bin ich wieder bei dir und
sorry, wie fängt man jetzt an,
wenn man daran glaubt, vor allem.
Ganz strange.
So eine kleine Elrond, auch wenn du es
umdrehst, da bestimmt auch so der grüne
Punkt und diese Dinge, die da draufstehen.
Hasbro.
Artikelnummer, Preis noch. Ja, schon merkwürdig. Vielen Dank für diese erste Folge, das Podcast-UFO aus diesem Jahr. Ich glaube, dieses Jahr wird unser Jahr, oder? Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, das letzte Jahr war unser Jahr, dieses Jahr wird es nicht. Aber 2018 wird wieder gut, aber gut. Ich freue mich auf 2018. Ich glaube, 2018 wird richtig geil.
Bis dahin wünschen wir euch natürlich eine tolle Zeit.
Haut mal was raus und wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder, wenn es wieder heißt.
Herzlich willkommen zu Nein, wir haben keine Musik.
Da ist Podcast-Uvo, werden wir mal wieder sagen.
Lass uns mal Musik kümmern.
Lass uns mal wieder einen Angriff nehmen.
Das hatten wir schon so halbfertig, aber dann ist es wieder runtergegangen.
Ja, weil wir kein Geld haben, aber jetzt haben wir wieder Geld.
Alles da.
Bis dann, macht's gut, ciao! Ja, das hatten wir schon so halbfertig, aber dann ist es wieder runtergegangen. Ja, weil wir kein Geld haben, aber jetzt haben wir wieder Geld. Alles da. Mane, mane!
Bis dann, macht's gut, ciao!